skyy gazers are still reveling this
morning having witnessed the longest
so-called blood moon eclipse this
century Friday's display coincided with
Mars's closest approach to earth in 15
years in a thrilling celestial event
Seth Doane lucky guy yeah got all in it
was a show with global reach and no
ticket price the star stayed the same
only the foreground changed a skyscraper
in Malaysia
a temple in Greece and a statue in
Germany the full lunar eclipse and it's
brilliant Blood Moon could have been
seen by about seven billion of the
world's seven point four billion
inhabitants whether depending in Rome
Friday night's moon pulled focus from
the most famous of tourist sites what
we're seeing is the earth casting its
shadow on the moon the earth is blocking
the Sun so the only light that's making
it to the moon is what's refracted
through the Earth's atmosphere that
casts a reddish glow creating a Blood
Moon the longest lunar eclipse of this
century made an irresistible subject for
a group of amateur photographers what do
you think he's fantastic
he says spectacular I don't think I see
a game I think like it is seen in my
life one time in a century in case
anyone missed it NASA put out a sort of
best of Blood Moon highlight reel Spacey
soundtrack and all astronomer Brendan
Owens was almost giddy we think of the
moon has been our ever-present friend
unchanging but these moments make you
realize the earth is effectively a giant
ball in space casting this huge shadow
and normally there's nothing in the way
but in this case our little friendly
neighbor the moon is is immersed by the
earth shadow and it gives you a
connection to space and in a way it
provided a connection to one another
they gazed at the same moon in Gaza in
Israel in Egypt all the way down under
in Australia and to the Far East in Hong
Kong this show had no particular plot
but left global audiences
for CBS this morning Saturday death dome
Rome wow what a show it was
photographers that capture that thank
God for that
I never compete we never saw it I'm a
running joke with Seth all the time I
say you were always in the right right
that's in your a good intro